[Musique]
étrangère
[Applaudissements] [
Musique
] [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
étrangère [Musique] étrangère [Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] étrangère [Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
et tu n'es pas
gentil
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
merci
[Musique] [Musique
]
éléphants
[Musique]
étrangère
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étrangère [Musique] étrangère [Musique] [Musique]
étrangère [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements]
étrangère [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étrangère [Musique
] étrangère [Musique
] [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
étrangère [
merci
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci